yeah look i i agree with you he had that
one play where he got the ball
on a reverse and and fumbled it and
could have had a disaster for the
steelers
he did make a nice recovery but you know
he's not a selfish player he really
isn't
i i when i spoke to him after that
breakout game against the eagles he said
hey if they start double covering me if
they put a safety over the top that's
what i want because it's going to make
everything
easier for the rest of the players and i
have a feeling when he's on the field
now
they are paying special attention to
chase clay point it may be one of the
reasons why i didn't have as much
production all right uh for me it's it's
easy and i'm not going to spend much
time on it steven guskowski missing the
45-yarder that would have forced
overtime we've seen this narrative and
when you are going to live on the edge
like the titans do
you've got to make your kicks you need a
kicker you can trust
and mike frable continues to trust
guskowski and
i guess statistically if every week
there's going to be a kick that either
wins the game
loses the game or forces overtime you're
gonna miss some
but that's what the titans life has been
most weeks
and uh guzzkowski has to be feeling
badly about
what transpired all right let's get to a
play to take a closer look at shereen
what did you pick
well i picked the one with 240 left the
steelers led by three at that point they
had the third and 12 at the tennessee
19. tennessee had used two of their
three timeouts
and ben went for it all in the end zone
and throws the interception that
bounces off juju's hands all you see in
the picture are titans there's four
titans around them
and a monty hooker ends up with the
interception but i wanted the steelers
there
i know i realized a touchdown put you
two scores ahead
but if the titans never get the ball
back they're you're gonna win the game
right so i would have liked to
have seen them pick up the first down
burn the clock
burn off the time and then even if you
get the field goal the titans don't have
very much time and they have to score a
touchdown to beat you and it almost
backfired on the steelers the
interception that big ben threw and he
didn't have a good game i'm surprised we
haven't talked more about him
because the three interceptions almost
sunk sunk the steelers
and he does have to play better but i
just thought that was a huge play in the
game
that let the titans open the door for
the titans to come back and ultimately
miss the field goal
and i think big ben was stunned when
they did miss that field goal
well one interception was on a batted
ball but the other two were in the end
zone the one at the end of the first
half was
ridiculous i don't know what he was
thinking what he was doing they were in
range for a fairly long field goal they
could have gone in at the half up 27-7
uh that that was unfortunate and you
know i watched that play
several times the one that you've
selected at the end
there was an opening there and i guess
anytime you've got a linebacker
on a receiver you take your shot
and the ball was just off and look we're
talking about
the best passers in the world a guy
who's been doing it for years
a guy who can place the ball wherever he
wants to place it
he just put it too far to
his left and it was in position where
juju had to reach around the linebacker
the ball got popped up in the air and
that was that you place that thing
just a little bit more to the right and
it's one hell of a throw
and assuming he holds on it's one hell
of a catch and it's game over
but it just shows you how how narrow
that margin can be and we marvel at when
a quarterback throws
a ball that threads the needle sometimes
they don't thread the needle
and something like that happens and it
opens the door for the titans to force
over time
my play was the brett kern punt that
that led to the first
interception and it wasn't a punt
because he didn't punt it he had a low
snap
he freaked out he started to run
toward the line i don't know what they
coach these guys to do in that moment
and i don't know whether any coaching
ever takes because he starts to run
toward the line a guy's coming at him
and he throws the ball well
anyone with half a brain knows that if
you throw the ball in that setting
everyone's going to be illegally
downfield everyone's going to be
and if you really wanted to and i unders
look i don't want to be
punters aren't athletes i'd like to
assume that these guys are sufficiently
athletic that he could have done like a
rugby punt
just to get the ball past the line of
scrimmage down the field
and farther away than where it was when
you throw an incomplete pass or
you know you have a penalty that
nullifies it anyway so i was stunned by
that
and it just you don't expect to see that
number one you don't expect to see a low
snap you take that for granted and you
don't expect the punter to freak out
shireen the way that he did but he just
freaked out
and how bad did the titan special teams
hurt them and it
it's hurt them the last couple years and
they better get that fixed and they
better get it fixed in a hurry but
the the dichotomy here of i had just
finished watching the rams game
and you see johnny hecker does do what
he did which is
fi all five punts at the 10 yard line or
inside the 10 yard line then i go watch
this game
frank kern was awful and you know he
gave up the long
return to ray ray mcleod that created a
short field for the steelers that they
converted there they started at the
tennessee 17.
then he tried to run on that one and
they were fortunate they've been through
that interception because they had
another short field there but
they've got to get those special teams
fixed before they get to the playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports